first of all
i want to welcome you to google next
2021.
in this session i will focus on what
role integrated observability tools play
in helping development teams become
elite performing teams
so without further delay let's get
started
my name is rakesh duber
i'm a director of product management at
google
i focus on our products related to cloud
observability
in today's session i will touch on five
areas
first i will start by talking about what
do we mean by the term elite performing
teams
while transformation towards becoming an
elite team usually requires a wide
variety of changes including adhering to
certain operational principles
evolving operational processes
and adopting a variety of tools
in this session i will focus on
observability tools only
we call our offering for observability
the cloud op suite
i will then dive deeper into some of the
specific capabilities that help
developers and operators reduce the time
they need to spend on identifying
diagnosing and troubleshooting problems
now this part of the talk will focus on
how we make it easier to instrument and
collect telemetry signals
and analyze them effectively to improve
troubleshooting
lastly
i will talk about how developers and
operators can overcome friction between
the two teams so that they can move fast
while maintaining reliability of their
services
so let me first start by defining what
we mean by the term elite teams
and to illustrate that i will refer to a
quote from the dora report so some of
you may be wondering what is the dora
report
now at its very foundation dora is an
ongoing research program sponsored by
google
it is the largest and longest-running
research program of its kind
the research program collects and
analyzes data from over 30 000
practitioners
and analyzes the practices that drive
their software delivery and operations
performance
participating organizations are measured
on metrics for software development
metrics for software deployment
and metrics for service operations
from this collected data we then do
cluster analysis to benchmark
organizations against the industry and
identify
characteristics that are grouped into
cohorts for low
medium high and elite performers
elite teams are the highest performers
on at least one of the metrics measured
for either software development
software deployment or service
operations
now one of the most interesting findings
from this research is that many
professionals approach these metrics as
representing a set of trade-offs
now these professionals believe that
increasing throughput of software
development will negatively impact the
availability and reliability of their
services
however to the contrary this research
has consistently shown for the last six
years that speed and stability are
outcome that enable each other
simply stated elite performers are able
to move fast and deploy their code
rapidly without compromising on service
reliability
the research also found that elite teams
were able to deploy multiple times a day
while low performers were deploying less
than once per month
at the same time these elite performers
had a time to restore a service of less
than one hour while the low performers
reported between one week to one month
i'm going to briefly talk about one of
our customers in more detail
and that customer is looks
so lowes is one of the largest
do-it-yourself home improvement retailer
in the united states
now as a part of their digital
transformation efforts they decided to
modernize some of their applications
using google cloud
now as they went through this business
transformation they work closely with
google to transform their organization
from a traditional i.t ops organization
to an sre type organization
for their observability tools they
picked our cloud-native capabilities
offered by the cloud operation suite
while they embarked on this journey in
2019 in early 2020 they had to
accelerate this transformation effort
the pandemic forced more and more
customers to transact online
and they had to integrate these cloud
native apps with pricing systems that
were running on-prem and with many
store-based inventory systems so that
they could fulfill customer orders from
a particular store in a timely manner
then during the black friday cyber
monday period their transaction volume
increased by three times of their
already high daily volume
lows handled the entire workload and
their observability challenges without
any hiccups
the results they shared with us were
simply amazing
they were able to reduce their mean time
to acknowledge from 30 minutes to one
minute
their mean time to restore a service
from two hours to 20 minutes
while increasing their development
velocity by 300x
they were able to move from
one monolithic release every two weeks
to 20 plus releases a day
now that's quite a story
so let's
dive into the observability tools
offering from google
collectively we call these capabilities
cloud operation suite
cloud operation suite is google's
observability solution that was designed
for scale it includes cloud monitoring
cloud logging and advanced observability
tools
cloud monitoring captures and analyzes
system and application metrics
it also enables users to define and
monitor service level objectives
and it automatically tracks
corresponding error budgets
cloud logging offers users the ability
to aggregate system and application logs
and explore these logs with an intuitive
log explorer ui
our advanced observability tools include
cloud trace
and that enables users to track how
requests are propagating through your
applications or microservices and
receive detailed real-time insights
now it is important to highlight the
cloud logging and monitoring are both
built on the same platform that google
uses internally for its sre operations
now as a result as your application
scale you don't have to worry about
scaling your observability tools
google cloud logging processes about two
and a half exabytes of log data every
month
now while most enterprises may not
require that level of scalability
you should feel comfortable that the
logging and monitoring systems will be
able to scale not if
but when your business needs suddenly
change and you witness an order of
magnitude more users
or are faced with any kind of
cloud-burst use cases
and that
has actually happened with several of
our customers and i will share a couple
of examples here
gannet a media company that owns usa
today
they saw an order of magnitude higher
number of users on election night 2020
in the us
in another example
one of our gaming customers so they saw
their users expand overnight
every time
they launched new games
so they have easily seen more than a
million users join over a very short
period of time
and in both cases the customers were
able to scale their applications and
along with those applications their
observability solutions
similarly our monitoring service is also
based on a highly scalable time series
platform
when applications were monolithic and
deployed on a small number of named
servers the volume of metrics in
monitoring tools was not very high
now with a move to kubernetes and
microservices-based architectures the
number of components generating metrics
has gone way up
in some instances we have seen that
metric volumes have actually gone up by
almost 100 times
also because of the ephemeral nature of
components
the granularity of metrics has shifted
from one minute collection frequency
down to 10 second collection frequency
and sometimes even down to one second
collection frequency
all of these have created
ex extremely high requirements on
scaling the underlying time series
platforms
and we want to make sure that we provide
a platform that scales to meet your
toughest scaling requirements
so with that high level overview let us
first look in how users can instrument
their applications and collect telemetry
signals from systems and applications
that are running on gcp
instrumentation and data collection have
always been a challenge in it and we
have seen a proliferation of agents over
the past two decades
google has been a strong proponent of
open standards and we've been actively
driving open telemetry standard for
service instrumentation and signal
collection
now as the standards evolve and mature
we have been adopting it in our products
to make it easier for developers to
instrument their applications
the open telemetry standard consists of
consists of three key things a
language specific api and sdk for
developers to instrument their
applications
b the open telemetry collector and
receivers for collecting signals
and c the open telemetry exporter for
sending data to different vendors for
storage visualization and alerting
we're currently working on instrumenting
our client libraries with open telemetry
starting with the grpc library
we believe that as the open telemetry
standards mature across all three signal
types it will provide huge benefits for
developers to start instrumenting their
applications from the very beginning
rather than wait for incidents to happen
and then have the operations team define
what needs to be instrumented in the
application
secondly to provide out-of-the-box
support for open telemetry we recently
released the unified ops agent
the unified ops agent makes it easier to
install configure and upgrade the
collection agent
this unified agent combines the
monitoring and logging agent into one
installable component and provides a
single yaml-based configuration language
we're migrating our third-party
application stack monitoring plugins to
become open telemetry based receivers
and those should be available through
the rest of this year
now prometheus is a very popular open
source monitoring service in kubernetes
environments now in the spirit of
openness and support for open source we
support and integrate with prometheus in
two ways
first we have integrations with the
prometheus engine to make it easier for
users to ingest kubernetes metrics and
workload metrics from prometheus to
cloud monitoring and leverage the rich
capabilities in cloud monitoring that
includes alerting dashboarding and
metric query language
second we recently announced the google
managed prometheus service for users who
want to continue using prometheus but do
not want to stand up the infrastructure
behind prometheus on their own and then
manage the prometheus service
now for gke environments specifically we
have made signal collection
even easier one of the key benefits of
cloud ops is that users do not have to
deploy any agents for collecting metrics
and logs in gke environments
not only does this reduce the toil of
deploying agents
this is very critical in kubernetes
environments because the containers are
ephemeral and in some cases the
containers may have very short lifespans
as they are automatically scaled up and
down based on policies
this automatic collection includes key
metrics for a variety of gke objects
including nodes pods and clusters
in addition to the system logs
application logs that are written
standard out and standard error are
automatically collected as
well now more importantly the
pre-configured agent automatically
captures metadata and the hierarchical
relationships amongst all of the
kubernetes objects from clusters to
nodes to services all the way to pods
and containers
as we will see later these relationships
come in very handy when users are
exploring observability data for
diagnosing problems
let us now briefly look at what
capabilities we provide for signal
analysis and visualization
as part of the cloudout suite we offer
an out-of-the-box gke dashboard
the dashboard provides a very rich and
powerful experience that was
purpose-built for gke
the dashboard aggregates all metrics
logs service level objectives kubernetes
events and alerts into one place for all
of your gke clusters
entities and their data presented in
this dashboard are related to each other
using the contact graph that i talked
about on the previous slide
when the context graph is not visible in
the ui when you start filtering data in
this dashboard
the presence of the context graph
becomes evident
the filtering is not just a text or
label based filtering but the filtering
in this dashboard happens based on the
relationships in the context graph
so for example when users filter for a
specific cluster
only objects that belong to that cluster
will be shown in the dashboard
each section of the dashboard from
namespace to node to service will be
filtered based on whether or not they
belong to the specific cluster
similarly when a user filters based on
the name of a pod again all the objects
that are not related to this pod will be
filtered out
only the cluster the namespace the node
and the service that this part belongs
to will be shown in the dashboard
now this is extremely powerful and a lot
of work has actually gone into scaling
this kind of filtering and presenting
all of this data in an aggregated manner
cloud operations offers purpose-built
explorers for each of the three
different types of signals namely
metrics logs and traces
so for metrics we offer the metrics
explorer for analyzing time series data
for creating charts as well as for
adding these charts to a dashboard
for advanced metric analysis we offer
the metric query language which provides
a powerful query based mechanism to
manipulate this time series data
using these queries users can compute
ratios of metrics
users can perform time shift analysis
users can analyze arbitrary percentiles
and users can evaluate arbitrary
mathematical expressions on this time
series data
similarly the logs explorer was
purposely purpose built for analyzing
logs
the logs explorer provides a histogram
view that helps users analyze log trends
writing log analysis queries can be
tedious
you know so we've made it a lot easier
to create save and share queries for
analyzing these logs
for richer analysis of log data users
can extract and analyze fields from log
data as well as define streaming alerts
on individual log events
logs can also be converted into metrics
and then users can leverage all of the
capabilities available in cloud
monitoring which includes visualization
learning dashboarding or defining slos
on these logs based metrics
lastly the trace explorer provides an
interface that makes it easy to
visualize all traces
and associated latencies
filter traces of interest based on
different criteria
and define alerts on trace data
so that users can do behavioral
comparison of how the latency of a
specific trace compares over time
while dke dashboard provides a curated
and tailored experience for
based apps many customers still need to
build custom dashboards
we did quite an extensive amount of uex
research over the past year to
understand what users need when they are
actually creating these dashboards
based on that research we have created a
pretty intuitive experience for creating
and editing the editing custom
dashboards
there's a variety of new chart types
dynamically resizable charts
easy way to drag and drop editing on a
dashboard
as well as use the full power of the
metrics query language within the
dashboard itself to explore the data
before you add it to a dashboard now one
of the interesting chart types we've
added recently is the alert chart type
when a user adds this chart to the
dashboard they can also associate an
alert policy with that chart
and users can then see the alert
threshold from that policy on this chart
finally
to automate the creation of dashboards
we have populated a github repository
with over 60 dashboard templates
and a terraform module to automate the
deployment of these templates
in addition we recently added a sample
dashboard capability directly into the
product ui
that makes it easy to ingest and adapt
these sample dashboards from the github
repository
users can get a preview of each of these
dashboards without any effort before
they start adapting and adopting these
sample dashboards
let us finally look at how development
teams can become elite performing teams
and the most important thing we will
discuss in this section is how the two
teams can collaborate amongst each other
while the collaboration between
development and ops teams can be
improved by defining and measuring
service level objectives that is easier
said than done
to improve that collaboration we
recommend that both developers and
operators have a seat at the design
table early on in the software design
process
so they can agree to a common language
agree on a best way to measure
reliability
and create reliability as a shared
objective for the two teams
now once they have agreed to the service
level indicators and what service level
objectives they want to achieve
they can then use these capabilities
within the service monitoring feature
and cloud operations
cloud monitoring or service monitoring
will automatically and continuously keep
track of how the teams are doing with
respect to the agreed slo
the error budget
is automatically computed and tracked as
well
now as long as the error budget for a
given time period has not been exhausted
developers can move with full velocity
to continue pushing out new capabilities
however as the error budget gets close
to exhaustion the mechanism becomes
self-regulating new features are slowed
down and both developers and operators
shift towards improving the service
reliability
now as organizations improve the
collaboration between developers and
operators around slos
they also need to adopt some best
practices that we have shared
these best practices include a accepting
that failure is normal
and not striving towards a hundred
percent slo
b
measuring everything including toil and
reliability
and using automation and observability
tools to reduce toil so developers and
operators can contribute towards feature
velocity
lastly when an incident does happen we
recommend that the two teams strive
towards blameless postmortems and drive
service reliability improvements
let us look at how customers can use
service monitoring to adopt and
implement some of these sre principles
the service monitoring capabilities
enables users to select a service level
indicator and define the service level
objectives
now once the slo is defined
file monitoring will automatically
compute and track error budgets
users can also define alerts on these
error budgets so as you reach a critical
threshold on your error budgets alerts
will be generated and users will be
notified about the exhaustion of the
error budget
for gke services there is further out of
the box integration that makes it easier
to define the service level objectives
cloud ops will automatically discover
services that are using istio and asm
deployed on gke
so when a user defines an slo for these
auto discovered services if they choose
an availability or latency metric cloud
ops will automatically pick or recommend
the metric
for
to be used as a service level indicator
now since some customers choose
prometheus to monitor kubernetes
services and specifically their apps
running on kubernetes we also provide
out-of-the-box integration for such
customers to ingest metrics from
prometheus and be able to define slis
and slos on prometheus metrics
of course users can define custom
services or choose any other custom
metric to be to use as an sli and then
define an slo on that metric
so let me summarize some of the key
highlights from this talk
first
like we have seen from the analysis in
the dora report and from the customer
example i talked about elite teams can
achieve high feature velocity without
sacrificing service reliability
two from a tools point of view cloud
operations offers integrated
capabilities that brings together the
three different signals to make it
easier to improve mttr
and enable developers and sre users to
focus on increasing code velocity
three
elite teams use slis and slos as a
mechanism to formalize reliability
targets between developers and operators
and customers can use these capabilities
within cloud operations
if you're interested in more sessions
around this topic or interested in
learning about our cloud operation suite
there are four additional three
additional sessions listed on this slide
and i welcome you to go watch those
please enjoy those sessions and other
sessions in
next 2021 and thank you again for
attending the session
you